what have you learned the last few years
of censorship counseling about religions
you can't say anything about muslim okay
they're not tolerant when it comes down
to bashing their religion you can't say
anything about Judaism if you do you
could potentially get canceled all over
the place but say anything you want
about Christianity and it's like it's
okay you can make a comedy thing a skid
make fun of them they're totally fine
because Christians are known for being
the most tolerant religion and in
America Christians have been like it's
okay it's okay it's okay and finally
they're saying dude I am no longer okay
you're pushing the envelope with my kids
and I'm sick of it and they're starting
to find themselves so let me tell you
what I got here I got a bunch of polls
from Gallup I got studies on black
Democrats versus white Democrats on how
they stand towards lgbtq transgender
same-sex marriage we're going to look at
some of the most tolerant countries in
the world towards same-sex marriage
we're also going to hear a message from
Malcolm X on what he had to say many
years ago which for some of you gonna
listen to say holy flipping Molly but
we're definitely going to tell such this
uncomfortable issue of same-sex marriage
in this episode
[Music]
this one's a tough one ain't it you kind
of like looking at seeing this pattern
really going into this I am by the way
if you get value out of this video give
it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel but here's what prompted this
episode a Gallup poll came out recently
saying fewer in U.S say same-sex
relations morally acceptable now Gallup
is not left it's not right it's in the
middle similar to peer research here's
what they have to say they had a lot of
different issues to see the plus minus
such as birth control divorce you know
having a baby outside of marriage
gambling death penalty abortion
everything is there but the one that had
the biggest plus minus was gay or
lesbian relations we went from 2022 71
being okay with it to a drop of seven
percent now down to 64 which by the way
even Democrats went from 85 percent to
79 saying they're okay with same-sex
marriage this is kind of strange when
you look at this right so we said let's
look at this even a little bit more how
how did this happen did we all of a
sudden become more conservative with it
do we all of a sudden as a nation say no
no no no no we're not okay with this I
don't know but there's definitely some
things to go even deeper on to take a
look at another Gallup poll came out
with the following question do you think
gays or lesbians should or should not be
hired for each of the following
occupations there's a bunch of them I'm
only going to touch a few of them if you
want to see the rest of it we'll give
you the link to look at but let's take a
look at some of these occupations armed
forces in 1977 it was 51 yes they should
be hired for This Job 38 said no then in
1999 that 51 went to 70 and 2019 that 51
went to 83 percent yeah there's nothing
wrong with that okay fine Armed Forces
number two doctors went from 44 in 1977
to 75 percent in 1999 to now 91 percent
which means we don't care if somebody's
a gay doctor or straight doctor America
is okay with that next clergy these are
pastors priests 1977 36 percent 1999 54
today 72 72 percent of our gift a pastor
is gay okay that's America Next
Elementary School teachers okay which is
where your kids are going to be around
1977 was 27
1999 54 today 81 by the way so some of
you said Pat who cares if the elementary
school teacher is a gay teacher or not
well if they are you know your kids are
around it if you're okay with that great
if you're not no problem but that's how
America feels about it by the way I can
tell you from multiple families I talk
to local here there's a big private
school here that's around fifty thousand
dollars per year K through 12. so many
parents are taking their kids out of the
school because they've crossed a line on
way too much lgbtq pride and trying to
impose it on the students and a lot of
parents are saying listen you're not
what you used to be 20 years ago even
though I went here I'm taking all my
kids out and they're leaving to
different schools right around the
corner I hear this locally and I bet
this is happening all across the country
as well now next question from Gallup
you ready in your view is being gay or
lesbian something a person is born with
or due to factors such as upbringing and
environment look how much this has
changed since 1977. in 1977 only 13 said
this is something you're born with 56
said you're gay because your environment
in 1999 that 13 went to 34 and the
environment went down to 40 and then
I'll bring it to today born with 49
environment 32 so from 1977 which was
roughly 45 46 years ago to today we went
from 13 you think you're born with it
you're not to 49 yeah about half the
country says you're born this way that's
a pretty big difference just in 45 years
here's another controversial one that
some people aren't comfortable talking
about but I'm proud of the fact that
gallup's actually doing these kinds of
surveys do you think gays and lesbians
should or should not be allowed to adopt
children 1977 14 today 75 should gays
and lesbians be allowed to adopt
children just 45 years ago we're not
okay with it today 75 is okay with it
some will say well you think it's a bad
idea how about all these kids that need
a place to live who cares who cares them
whether they're gay or straight fine
some people say do you see about all
these other arrests that are coming out
with gay parents that are adopting kids
and what's happening to these kids yeah
but that doesn't happen all the time
either way there's an argument for both
sides so now let's take a look at
history when did this whole thing get
started when do we coin the term
homosexual you know when it was
1869 it was first coined by Hungarian
journalists Carl Maria Kurth Benny then
in 1897 the first known gay rights
organization called the scientific
humanitarian committee is founded in
Germany 1924 Magnus hirschfield
publishes the transvestites the
psychology of sex expression this was
one of the first scientific studies of
transgender people 1968 Congressional
proceedings reference gender identity
that occurs in a Report on Public Health
Service under the National Institute of
Mental Health summary of sex deviates
which included gender identity disorder
as a a future direction for research
that's 1968 under Lyndon Johnson if you
wonder who the president is 1971 the
first legal challenge to a state ban on
same-sex marriage was filed in Minnesota
1973 which by the way is only about 50
years ago if you think about it ready
the American Psychiatric association
removes homosexuality from its list of
mental disorder that means in 1972 being
homosexual was a mental disorder the
same 200 years ago folks this is just 50
years ago when we the Health Professions
used to think it was a mental disorder
to be gay 1973 it changed 1974 the first
gay pride marches are held in New York
Los Angeles and Chicago 1986 you ready
for this one Court's rule that there is
no constitutional protection for sodomy
in Bowers versus Hardwick ruling allows
sodomy to continue being criminally
prosecuted in states where laws prohibit
homosexual activity so why is this 1986
because the AIDS epidemic was in June of
81 and people were worried about what
was going taking place a lot of gay
folks were getting AIDS because the
whole concept of sodomy is what they're
talking about if you don't know what
Sodom is don't go Google it because some
sites may come up but that's kind of
what caused this 1986 ruling 1987 the
Supreme Court of the United States rules
that sexual orientation is not a
constitutionally protected class this is
87 okay how long ago was that 35 years
ago 36 years ago in 1988 1993 was the
don't ask don't tell policy prohibiting
lesbians gay and bisexual people from
coming out or telling others about
anything related to their sexual
activity anything related to their
sexuality is codified on this date same
year 1993 the Supreme Court of the
United States rules that the Boy Scouts
of America cannot discriminate against
gays and lesbian Scouts 1994 Big Year
the national educational Association Nea
passes a resolution calling for the
inclusion of lgbtq Topics in the
curriculum 1996 another interesting one
Congress passes the Defense of Marriage
Act at Doma which defines marriage as
between one man and one woman for
federal purposes signed by the one and
only Bill Clinton this was obviously a
major setback for the same-sex marriage
but it was overturned in 2013. 2003 the
Supreme Court of the United States rules
that same-sexual activity is illegal in
all 50 states 2004 Massachusetts becomes
the first state to legalize same-sex
marriage do you want to know who the
governor was Republican Governor Mitt
Romney 2005 the gay lesbian and straight
education Network releases its first
national school climate survey which
finds that lgbtq students are
disproportionately bullied and harassed
in schools which leads to 2008
California voters approved Proposition 8
which banned same-sex marriage in the
State 2009 Proclamation 8387 President
Barack Obama dedicates June as lesbian
gay bisexual and transgender pride month
2011 California passes the fair
Education Act which requires that all
public schools in the state teach about
the contributions of lgbtq community to
history and culture 2011 don't ask don't
tell is repealed 2013 gender identity
disorder updated to gender dysphoria in
the diagnostic and statistical Manual of
mental disorders in 2015 this is a big
one the Supreme Court rules in obra
giffel versus Hodges that the
fundamental right to marry is guaranteed
to same-sex couples by the due process
and equal protection Clauses of the 14th
Amendment this decision legalize the
same-sex marriage in all 50 states okay
so in 2016-2017 Barack Obama tried to
make it more inclusive for transgenders
to be able to participate and not get
judged Trump comes up and he revokes it
but then here's what happens to follow
in year in 2018 the White House
announces that most transgender people
are prohibited in the military okay then
in 2020 a letter from Department of
Education announces that the inclusion
of transgender athletes in sports teams
based on their gender identities a title
9 violation this motion effectively bans
transgender athletes from participating
in sports so look why are all these
parents I mean you've seen Glenda what's
going on with the protesting parents are
coming out saying us if you were sick
and tired of Glendale Unified School
District and it's happening across the
country but how did all this material go
into schools why are why are public
school teachers teaching this stuff it's
pissing off parents how do we get here
you have to know who's behind it all for
example do you remember how we talked
about earlier about the California
passing the fair accurate inclusive Act
of 2011 which requires all public
schools in the state to teach about the
contributions of the lgbtq people to
history and culture that's kind of how
it happened it was something that passed
but more importantly policies that make
lgbtq related material mandatory in
schools are typically approved by state
legislatures in some cases these
policies are the result of grassroot
activism while in other cases they are
initiated by government officials once
it's a policy it is then implemented by
school district and who was the most
responsible for the California fair
Education Act you ready these
organizations equality California gay
lesbian and straight education Network
Human Rights Campaign HRC National
Center for lesbian rights transgender
Law Center and what do these
organizations have in common you ready
they have the same three donors and do
you want to know who's behind these
three donors I wonder who do you want to
take a while I guess you probably will
get it right let me give it to you first
one is Gilead Sciences in 2001 they
became the first company to develop a
once daily pill for the treatment of HIV
and AIDS that's one of the biggest
funders and by the way you know who's
been a shareholder up there since 1999
Soros fund management and in 2015 Soros
fund management was one of the investors
in a group that acquired a majority
stake in FEMA's Medicare A company that
provides Specialty Pharmacy services to
patients with HIV and AIDS and Gilead
Sciences is a major customer of Themis
Medicare the second Foundation is called
the Arcus foundation and George Soros is
a trustee of the Arcus foundation and
has donated millions of dollars to this
foundation and the third one ready the
Gill Foundation which who do you think
is a trustee George Soros is a trustee
and has donated millions of dollars to
the foundation's work a little weird why
is this guy behind it why are you so
concerned about kids and wanting to
teach this to them like how's it matter
to you George Soros why do you care so
much it's a valid question for parents
to ask why he's funding this by the way
as of June 2023 there are six states
that make it mandatory to teach lgbtq
related material in schools Ready
California Colorado Illinois Nevada
Jersey and Oregon so look I don't know
where you stand or what you're going to
be saying but either way you're probably
like what the hell is about this kind of
uncomfortable to talk about this stuff
you either watching and saying I can't
stand you doing this this is why I hate
Valentine and pvdm no problem or you
were saying is wow I never knew about
this stuff I'm kind of interested in
what else he has to say I want to kind
of look at some religions if you were to
look at which one is the most tolerant
to same-sex marriage and which one is
the least if we have to say Muslim
that's the least tolerant but the most
tolerant is Catholics and this is
according to Pure research it's followed
by Jews then mainly line Protestant then
historically black Protestant then
Mormons at 27 percent and the least
tolerant is the Evangelical Protestant
and by the way why don't we look at U.S
world news on what countries are the
most tolerant to same-sex marriage
here's what you will find according to
U.S news if we look at these 24
different countries you see at the top
where it says totally opposed strongly
opposed someone opposed somewhat favor
strongly favor or total favor score all
the way to the right here's what you'll
find Canada 79 U.S 63. but look at this
the country with the highest
favorability score is Sweden with 92
then it's Netherlands then Spain France
then Germany you can look at the rest
the lowest believe it or not is Hungary
in that list with 31 but if you go to
other countries such as Indonesia which
is the largest Muslim country in the
world it's got the lowest score with
five outside of Nigeria and even Kenya's
at nine and Israel is at 36. it tells
you most Christian nations are tolerant
and those that are Muslim nations are
not tolerant for same-sex marriage as if
I haven't pissed you off enough with
this data that we're sharing with you
I'm going to share with you from Pew
research and here's what it says unlike
other Democrats a majority of black
Democrats say gender is determined by
sex at Birth so these are black
Democrats these are folks who were
really needing civil rights at one point
just 60 years ago now they're kind of
saying civil rights is different than
gay rights if you look at this here's
what it says so unlike other Democrats
the majority of black Democrats say
gender is determined by sex at Birth if
you look at this year the yellow to the
left is determined sex assigned at Birth
the blue on the right is can be
different from sex assigned at Birth if
you look at the Republican leaning
you'll see 86 say no your sex is
determined at Birth 13 say you can
change but look at the white 72 percent
say it can be different from sex
assigned at Birth but look at blacks
only 33. that's a 40-point discrepancy
and blacks are 66 percent saying it's
different Remember by six separate you
know what it says blacks are closer to
Republicans than white liberals they
have a 40 Point difference Hispanics are
at 44 and Asians are at 38 but blacks
are the least tolerant on this topic
according to Pew research here's another
one man black Democrats are going to
piss off a lot of the white Democrats
when you see this and and this is purely
their data I didn't do this here you can
get upset up here research and write a
negative review about them because these
guys are pissing off some of the wrong
people watch this one Democratic K
through 12 parents deferred by race
ethnicity over what kids should learn in
school about gender identity look at
this here percentage-wise I mainly want
to look at the left one here which is
the green one where it says someone can
be a boy or a girl even if it's
different from sex at Birth Republicans
say no nine percent agree with this
white said 64 yes you can be different
than what you were born with but black
said 30 percent do you realize blacks
are only 21 away from Republicans and 34
away from white Democrats how weird is
that my experience on being in the
military are my black friends or selling
memberships at valleys or working in the
financial industry for last 20 years
with our African-American Community the
grandmothers and the mothers are
typically very conservative so this
makes sense to me and by the way I just
want you to watch this one video but by
this guy you may know this guy's name is
Malcolm X he gave the speech many many
years ago comparing the difference
between what a white liberal is versus a
white conservative and the only reason I
want you to watch a speech if you've
never seen this before is because in
this context we're comparing black
Democrats white Democrats here's what
Malcolm X had to say about this many
many decades ago
the white liberal differs from the white
conservative only in one way
the liberal is more deceitful more
hypocritical
than the conservative
both want Power
but the white liberal is the one who has
perfected the art of posing as the
negro's friend and benefactor
and by winning the friendship in support
of the Negro the white liberal is able
to use the Negro as a pawn or a weapon
in this political football game that is
constantly raging between the white
liberals and the white conservatives
the American Negro is nothing but a
political football
and the white liberals control this ball
through tricks
or tokenism
false promises of integration and civil
rights
in this game of deceiving and using the
American Negro the white liberals have
complete cooperation of the Negro civil
rights leader who sell our people out
for a few crumbs of token recognition
token games
token progress
so what'd you think about his message
what do you think about what he has to
say you think they liked what he had to
say he's he's calling everybody out and
by the way there's a part of America
today that believes that they're like
wait a minute I don't relate to what's
going on in America today I love America
I'm a John F Kennedy Democrat I love
what America stood for I'm not part of
all this craziness here's a stat that
just came out that shows What's Going On
by Generation by Generation by
generation this is pissing off parents
so let me get this straight so
traditionalists people being born before
1946 only 1.7 percent of them are part
of the lgbtq community as if they're
afraid to come out of the closet you
know how people say well because people
are more comfortable today to come out
no no there isn't anybody that's more
comfortable who doesn't give a
about what you and I think then the
older generation they don't care which
one I think like I'm 72 years old I'm
gay I don't care if you like they don't
care whether you think anything about it
or not they're only at 1.7 percent baby
boomers are at 2.7 percent Gen X is 3.3
percent Millennials born from 1981 to
1996 or 11.2 percent and gen Z kids born
from 1997 to 2004 20 one out of five
really that's really naturally that's
how they were or is this going back to
the Gallup thing that we looked at where
it says environment do you remember the
whole environment was a big part of it
yeah this is saying that we were smarter
50 years ago than we are today and by
the way remember how I started this and
I said there's four things I pray for
courage wisdom tolerance understanding
trust me takes courage to make this
video because I'm gonna get a lot of
hate for video like this but the
tolerance part it's starting to get to a
point that listen this concept of
Tolerance back in the days it was
Corinth now was a city that was Corinth
now America the greatest country in the
world is turning into corn the school
you're going to you're okay with that so
are we you know what happens typically
with tolerant people here's how tolerant
people are oh it's okay don't worry
about it it's fine yeah I'm not with it
but go for it yeah it's cool a little
bit of Tolerance fine all of a sudden
you realize I think that guy's taking
advantage of my tolerance
am I being preyed on am I being abused a
little bit listen you're not doing this
anymore we'll cry you cross the line
with my kids we're staying right here
and by the way I'm Middle Eastern
I fall in a very weird category yeah
I've experienced all these other things
hey you know you're discriminating
you're from your graduates I I
understand why somebody would say that
for being from Iran totally get it I'm
from Iran I get it
but
women's rights
there is no debate of course we have to
have woman's rights civil rights
absolutely I don't care if I'm darker
than you or whatever I am yes gay rights
has turned into a religion where
everybody's walking on eggshells
especially the Christian Community
because we are seeing you guys are
tolerant so we can take advantage of you
and Muslims say listen man pump the
brakes we're right here we don't play
the games here go do that on America not
in our country oh oh okay well respect
it but no in America these guys are
cowards they're so tolerant you can take
advantage of them and based on some of
the data I think people are waking up
and they're saying maybe we can learn a
little bit from Muslims maybe we can
learn a little bit from them they don't
compromise their standards and maybe
Christians need to start realizing we
also don't need to compromise our
standards and start speaking up again if
I pissed you off awesome that was the
purpose of this content to get you
thinking if you're watching this and
you're like I was not planning for me to
wake up this morning thinking about this
topic but holy here we go now I got
a text this to my mom and dad and my
husband and my wife and my best friend
say do you agree what Pat has to say I
don't care all I want to do with our
team of research team that brought all
this content we're we're all thinking
just like you are I'm starting to say I
didn't know this I didn't know this I
didn't know this wow that's pretty crazy
and if you feel that way share this with
others and talk about it and if you're a
parent and your blood pressure went up
the last 20 minutes we're doing some
events around the country for parents I
may be doing one in the city I grew up
in where I went to school because a lot
of parents are frustrated with Glendale
Unified School District but if you're a
parent and you want to know if we do any
other events or parents in a city coming
near you text the word parents to
310-340-1132 once again text the word
parents to
310-340-1132 we will let you know if we
do any events in your city and if you
want to watch a video as a parent how to
go fight for your kids we did a video
here specifically for you if you haven't
seen it click here to watch that video
take care everybody bye-bye
thank you